well I've been asked to make a statement
here in Davos which is a burnished in
place we meet all kinds of different
personalities and people and even though
I'm in politics I was thinking that I
might say a few words about innovation
and how I see it concerning a particular
technology but I also see that it has a
political dimension we are facing in the
world so many major challenges I would
say that the younger generation today is
facing the biggest challenges humankind
has faced in the past in its history and
in order to deal with this we need to
work together we need to pull our forces
whether it's on climate change and
financial crisis on poverty and
inequality whether it's on the issues of
migration multicultural societies were
living in but we also need to find
innovative solutions innovation from
technical solutions innovation in
politics itself and how we deliberate
how we work how we use this issue like
web platforms like web 22 to have
interactive democratic participated such
a solution but how do we create an
environment of innovation environment of
innovation is not simply chaos it is
creating the necessary platform stage
I'll take the example which I think most
people know is the pets ad iphone where
you see there is a specific platform
however this huge innovation with all
the apps that have been developed over
the last year or two so you have a surge
of innovation but you also have a very
secure environment so if you translate
that to politics that would mean us
creating societies with this secure
environment where people can feel secure
secure enough to take risks to be
innovative to take initiative and that
means that we politicians have to create
that environmental security of a quality
if you like
good education of good health services
and also freedom to take initiative I
would say of course that looking at
what's going on is what is fascinating
for me is how we bring innovation into
an area which you don't have too much
innovation which is education and now
with these new gadgets d books the
Kindles the iPad and so on I believe
that we're moving into an area where the
book will become much more electronic
much more interactive where you could
have a virtual school cyber school if
you like and people could both have the
the information that they want through
the through the net through the internet
but also be very interactive and the
classroom changing from my sort of
hierarchical structure too much more of
a gathering where you share the
experiences and your project you've
already developed and the communications
you've had on the net with in a live way
in life in a live group much more i
would say democratic much more
collective much more humane so in fact
technology can bring a much more humane
type of school and schooling and and
much more accessibility for all and much
more personalized development of
information and educational processes
from the richer countries to be more to
the poorer countries and developing
countries give access to this
Commonwealth if you like which is we are
creating more and more which is this
common knowledge of humanity which has
to be accessible call